قبل اكمال عام على الاعمال العسكريه في
اوكرانيا يستانف الجيش الاوكراني قصفه
لمدينه دانيت هذه
احدى الاسواق التي تم قصفها 45 صاروخ
استهدفت مناطق مدنيه حيث
استهدفت صواريخ جراد وفمبير تشيكيه
وبولنديه الصنع مناطق مختلفه من المدينه
هنا هذه السوق فيها اثار احدى القذائف
التي سقطت على هذه المحلات التجاريه هذا
الامر لا يتوقف هنا في كل الاحياء وفي كل
مكان لا يوجد احياء لم تسقط فيها الغلايف
وصواريخ لقد احتدنا على ذلك
وتستمر الاعمال العسكريه بالقصف المتبادل
ما بين الطرفين الاوكراني والروسي وقد
استهدفت
الاوكرانيه عددا من المباني الحكوميه
والمباني السكنيه في المدينه وبعد هذا
القصف اوقف عمده دانيه العمل في شبكه
المواصلات المحليه هنا تحسبا من استمرار
القصف الاوكراني الذي ربما يخلف مزيدا من
القتلى ومن الضحايا وتستمر القذائف
والصواريخ بالسقوط على مناطق مختلفه في
قلب المدينه بشكل عشوائي وهذا موقع اخر
وهو مكتبه المدينه مكتبه
المدنيه موقع اخر فيه محل تجاريه تضررت
اثرى القصف هنا في هذا الموقع بالذات سقط
صاروخ من طراز جراد
لقناتي العربيه والحدث رائد الاغبر دانيت